would you have OJ on the podcast I've
been wanting to talk to him um I reached
out to him when he was in prison so I
sent him a couple of letters which was
really hard to do I tried to soften my
approach because I figured if I came at
it hard that he would it be an absolute
no so I tried to appeal to a softer side
to him how do you do that
Hoss I was 20 letters later I just him
in prison I did directly mm-hmm and he
got the letters I assumed he did I don't
know I ended up talking to his attorney
at the time Yale Galanter who we had a
couple of conversations about how that
conversation would look and how that
situation would go and he couldn't
protect me while I was in there and he
was worried about my safety he was
worried about my emotional well-being
and then the lawyer was mm-hmm and when
I assured him that I would be fine I'm
tough cookie he wanted me to sign an NDA
a nondisclosure agreement that it never
happened and I would never be able to
talk about it and I said no hmm wait a
second so I guess the idea that was is
that if oj spoke to you and maybe he
even said to you look okay I did it
he wanted the assurance that you
wouldn't go public with it and
essentially that's what he told me I
mean he was very candid with me and I
appreciated that um and he kept saying I
can't protect you while you're in there
do you think I mean I don't know that
you would know because you don't really
know him but do you think he has any
actual remorse do you think that he lays
down at night and says I'll [ __ ] I did a
horrible thing or do you think he
doesn't think he thinks he's innocent
you know he's either convinced himself
that he didn't do it I don't know if he
just thinks haha I pulled the wool over
everybody's eyes what has frustrated me
though is it he's never acknowledged the
bravery of my brother why does he have
such anger towards me and my family
financially if he was so innocent right
why wouldn't he be saying you know what
I just I want to thank Ron Goldman for
trying to save the mother of my children
and if he did it he killed the mother of
his children right
well Kim Goldman's podcast confronting
OJ Simpson is available wherever
podcasts are downloaded have you put it
out to him to come on your podcast and
and talk we have we've put it out to him
through his his attorney too and it's I
know people on pot on Twitter have been
talking
- you know it shifts for me the the
reason I'd want to confront him now
because the visual would be very
different because now he's able to you
know move about the cabin on his own but
I don't want to talk too much about what
I think I would say because then it kind
of defeats the purpose
yeah I wonder what you would say
actually because what would you say what
would you say I don't know you know
first of all I don't even know that I
could stomach being in the same room
with them because this situation is so
[ __ ] up yeah I don't think I would be
coherent I think I'd want to kill him
yeah I don't you know my anger my rage
would be too great you know I again I
keep going over to my brain I do feel
like I would have all of that rage you
know we only saw each other twice during
the the civil trial or I was able to be
in close proximity to him and I couldn't
get anything out I mean he was looking
at me up up and down like a piece of
meat and you know he kind of did like
that like you know but when he looked at
me and I was like don't look at me like
that and that was all I could say of all
the years that I've had no sexual work
yeah he kind of did like the ones are
pretty good so what do you think you
would say to him I think it would be
just that visceral reaction what I'm
feeling in that moment and maybe is just
what if he owned up and said to you I'll
tell you what I got nothing to lose here
I'm really sorry I lost my mind and I
killed your brother mm-hmm what would
you do I don't know yeah that's what I
mean I you know he thinks you're gonna
interview him about fantasy football
advice the debate